[Music]
recently i spent a lot of time studying
bebop it's been a long ongoing journey
full of ups and downs a lot of confusion
and some breakthroughs but it's led to a
lot of new insights about harmony rhythm
form
and also a new approach to composition
for me
later on in the video you'll hear some
new music that i wrote out of this whole
process but first i'd like to start off
with a quick rundown of things i wish
someone would have straightforwardly
explained to me a classically trained
pianist at the beginning of my journey
bebop is a specific genre of jazz that
began in the 40s defined by key players
that came after the swing era
unlike classical music where the score
gives you exact instructions as to what
notes to play the articulation dynamics
and phrasing in bebop as well as other
forms of jazz you have what is called a
lead sheet which gives you a blueprint
of the melody and harmony and sometimes
rhythm over which you improvise
a lot of these songs are popular tunes
from the time or tunes written by jazz
musicians themselves the letters and
symbols you see tell you the harmonic
progression of each tune and the
labeling is not the same as roman
numeral analysis
unless otherwise specified all chords
are looked at as chords with four notes
so instead of triads think seventh
chords
the notes that add color to each chord
are the pitches that are extended beyond
the first three notes of a triad so
after the first third and fifth pitches
consider also the 7th 9th 11th and 13th
pitches above the root of the chord
the written notation must not be taken
literally a swing feel is implied for
most tunes and the closest description
of it is a triplet feel but it's best
not to think about that so literally as
well
refer to recordings of bebop players to
understand this rhythm
emphasis is given on the off beats so on
the two and four of a four note grouping
and syncopation is a big part of the
rhythmic language
[Music]
the main melody is referred to as the
head and it's typically played once
through at the beginning followed by
multiple repetitions of the section
which is when soloists improvise over
the melody and harmony
[Music]
similar principles of melodic and
harmonic framework exist in both
classical music and jazz in terms of how
notes are added to elaborate on a given
harmony
one of the most common chord
progressions you'll come across is the
2-5-1 chord progression here it is in
c-sharp minor
[Music]
and here's an excerpt from chopin's
fantasy impromptu
what you just heard is also a 251 chord
progression
noticing this similarity is definitely
interesting but there is way more beyond
this
to gather a better understanding of
bebop i reached out to some of my
friends who are experts in this genre
here's amy nolte she's a fantastic jazz
pianist vocalist and educator and i've
learned a lot from her youtube channel
[Music]
all the charlie parker all the dingy
gillespie
it's all good
next i visited my friend glenn zalewski
who also has great videos on youtube and
is an internationally acclaimed jazz
pianist and composer
[Music]
what if i were to sing it like i would
sing that like
like very legato very smooth right um
but i could take the exact same line and
sing it in a bebop kind of way with just
a little bit of swing feel and a little
bit of inflection
same exact line you get a totally
different thing
all of a sudden right like just a
syncopated way of saying my
like everything changes
if you listen to charlie parker play
this
[Music]
you're trying to imitate his phrasing
which wouldn't be this
it would be more more gestural i mean
and you could look at the line on a
piece of paper and put accents
some notes that you definitely hear more
than others right there's a rhythm
underneath this which is like
[Music]
if we're trying to consider how to
phrase on the piano we should listen to
horn players yeah
[Music]
but where do they get their sense of
phrase where do they get it from
and that okay that's another good thing
so another important thing about bebop
is that it's essentially rhythmic music
[Music]
a lot of this
language comes
from the drums
[Music]
the drummer might play something like
this
and that could be imitated on the piano
like
or it could even be imitated by a line
[Music]
you know you can imagine that on a drum
set so uh damp it down
if they added a uh like a roll on one of
the notes that would be like an ornament
there's a bounce there's i hear
the bass being
emphasized but then
um the chords they're kind of punchy and
they're on the outfit yes
yeah good and and how do you
how do you know
how do you know when to do that
[Music]
like that that's not a bad one
so it's
one and on the end of one
one two and three and four and it was
like end of one three and a four hold it
out for the next bar that's pretty good
way to start
you know what i'm thinking about it's my
time i'm talking about
i'm filling up the bar and then if i if
i want to hit anywhere i got the correct
hit
you know instead of
relying on one two three four one two
i'm thinking about one one or two
attempts
if you're like
[Music]
that loses a certain element of
syncopation at some point we need to
hear
for example some sometimes we need to
hear upbeats and down beats at the same
time otherwise it's not really
it's not really syncopated his left hand
is very in the low register right
and it's kind of like this murmur
register but it's rhythmic like it's and
so it starts off with a specific bass
line
it's not all short
and you know you can't use the pedal
when you're doing it because then it
becomes all long
it can't this this this this rolls it
for that
this is partial feet
yeah yeah
yeah i am lucky
[Music]
another
element that's
used all the time in bebop is called the
enclosure
and i think i did i do it
[Music]
there's one so i know that the d flat's
my target on the b flat minor chord but
in order to get to it i go below it i go
above it i hit it does that it sits in
classical music all the time a lot of
times the way that bach would outline a
line
such as
is is also the way that charlie parker
would would outline his light just with
a different inflection
like you hear it all the time right yeah
it's the same i mean bebop is a very
ornamental language
it could be
[Music]
it's this thing that could go on all day
it could go on longer or kind of stop at
any time it's um
you're just tapping into kind of a
rhythmic flow you don't wonder like how
are they coming up with that stuff
you just you just think oh yeah they're
they're grooving right they're grooving
what's what is he playing
it's it's like uh it's like a d flat
seven kind of sound over the g7 you know
the difference between in the mood and
cheryl these are both blues right in the
mood is the blues
and aprivov what i just played is a
blues
this is in the mood
all right
and this is opera bob
so
on one hand in the most basic sense
the difference is
harmonic intricacy
so anyways for piano players i think the
harmony stuff's not that complicated
anyways right pianists are good at
harmony they they understand this stuff
pretty pretty quickly so
uh really
do you know the pianist barry harris
so he does a workshop every tuesday in
new york city do you know about this
of course i went to the workshop barry
harris is one of the most iconic
pianists and educators in bebop
so he talks a lot about the sixth
diminished scale and at first i was
really confused as to what it was
and what he's talking about
[Music]
i also heard that it varies from week to
week depending on who's there but when i
was there i was too shy to really get
close to the piano and there were just
too many people crowded around so i
couldn't weasel my way in so long story
short i ended up just being confused and
later on glenn helped me understand this
concept a little more and i spent some
time thinking about it and trying to
understand it on my own and in the next
three minutes i'll try to
explain it the best i can in the way
that i currently understand it
[Music]
so if you have a chord or a key center
for example c major
relative to this chord you'll have a
dominant chord so in this context it'll
be c major
g seven or g dominant seven back to c
[Music]
now in jazz and bebop
you add extensions especially to the
dominant chord so
to the first four notes you'll add
a flat nine
so this chord here
can be simplified as
a b diminished seventh chord because
these notes are the top four notes of a
g
seven flat nine chord
so to a c major scale
[Music]
which has seven notes
you'll add that added note
and now you have an eight note scale one
two three four five six seven eight
[Music]
so based on this you can organize these
eight notes
into two categories one is home base so
c major and the other is
diminished or the tension
notes
and since a diminished chord is built on
minor thirds
once you have the four notes that make
up
a particular diminished chord you can
really start it from anywhere
so that might look like this
[Music]
and the way he likes to voice it seems
is
[Music]
with the c6
for example in this mozart sonata
it's going from c
to
g dominant 7 or g7 back to c
so tonic dominant tonic
if you were to apply this sort of
concept with diminished chords it might
sound something like this
[Music]
maybe
it's kind of like finding ways to
embellish
main chords either by
harmonizing them or adding notes between
them
let's take 251 in c major
[Music]
and if we had a line like this
[Music]
applying these principles might turn it
into something like this
so diminished
non-diminished diminished
non-diminished
a g7 with extensions
resolving back to a non-diminished
i think
[Music]
if you're familiar with my channel
you've seen me immerse myself in
different genres and for me these genre
studies are like a form of traveling
it's almost like taking a trip somewhere
to learn about and experience something
new and coming back home with a few
souvenirs and most importantly something
that adds to and changes my perspective
of things back at home of course the
whole point of this is to find new
influences for my own writing now this
particular study led me in a few
directions at first i was going down a
path where i began to familiarize myself
with one of the most played bebop tunes
all the things you are first by
arranging it in the style of chopin
something i'm already familiar with
[Music]
after a while though i lost steam with
it while trying to translate these ideas
into a bebop style
[Music]
i think i was missing the point of it
all and was driven more by a certain
concept i had around this idea then
after a bit of a break from it all i
decided i would put more of a focus on
different aspects of influence i
gathered from bebop such as spontaneity
and imagination of harmony and phrasing
rather than trying to zone in on all of
the detailed characteristics of the
genre
i could walk into this room and i could
say
something about the lights you can say
something about before yeah
but we're talking about the same thing
exactly that is
an amazing analogy that's such a great
analogy you could do the same thing with
the chord change we could all be talking
about e flat minor seven someone else
could play this and someone else looks
like this
someone else could play this
and there's actually an infinite number
of things that you could say looking at
this room it did it's literally infinite
and just because it's improvised doesn't
automatically make it better than
something that's written and in fact
doesn't even make it automatically more
spontaneous you're very right chicaria
said that in an interview he said that
you shouldn't
you shouldn't confuse spontaneity and
differentness just because it's
different doesn't mean it's more
spontaneous
they're different
qualities after a while i started to get
to know the tune better and was
experimenting with it and got to a place
where naturally i felt like elaborating
on it and this is also around the time
when i started to look more into
reharmonization techniques
at this point i found great information
on rick viatto's channel over f sharp
one of the notes is a chord tone jeff
schneider's channel these two notes in
here that's the four resolving five the
flat six fifth mode of the harmonic
minor scale jens larson's channel
so that's the group of subdominant
chords
and many other videos on youtube
the music of the day owes
a lot
to be loved all of this eventually led
me to take on a completely different
approach which now brings me to my final
arrangement of the tune
ready
so
[Music]
[Music]
i think one of the biggest takeaways for
me was to take on a different approach
when it comes to creating music and
having more of a sense of freedom and
like i said before spontaneity
surrounding this and
really using
intuition and imagination like i said in
the beginning of the video this is an
ongoing process for me so look forward
to follow-up videos on this genre and
this subject and if you made it this far
in the video thank you so much for
watching and i'll see you in the next
video bye
[Music]
[Music]
you